this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
we have begun so welcome to engineering
and climate change and this is the
purpose of this course is to give you a
start on the tools and information
needed so that you can make a difference
on the challenges this brings here's our
graphical summary of what we're up to
we are on our fourth lecture of the
quarter we have done fold an hour a real
solar industry veteran and expert I
think you'll enjoy him a lot and we have
an ice expert a polar explorer next week
ice is really important in climate
change which is why I push that and if
anybody you don't even have to read the
whole thing if anybody wants to borrow
some of my two most precious books ice
in the ocean by Peter Wadhams or on thin
ice by Richard Ellis you're welcome to
them you will see later in the quarter
on the last lecture when I'll describe
my own project on ice I think ice is one
of those crucial items in climate change
so Doug is the the head of ice axe
expeditions he's been to the North and
South Pole more often than anybody else
on the planet so it'll be an interesting
talk in its own right very inspiring he
is and very into educating people at all
ages you know grade school on up through
through your level but he also places
experiments for environmental scientists
to help see what the effects of climate
change are and it's very very relevant
to one of the big levers on climate
change on the planet and then the
logistics I think there are actually
still a couple new students as people's
schedules fluctuate so we'll put this up
again of just what our logistics are if
you have missed any lectures please make
it up by looking at them on the videos
and then of course it's best to attend
live if you can right but if you are
remote or if you're making up please
look at those lectures and then please
send me a summary and I would much
prefer if you do it to the course works
site I have gotten some a No
emails from some of you about the course
worksite and I have collaborated with
experts here before the class what on
earth could be going wrong it takes a
little time for the coursework site to
load the assignments but they are there
and and most of you are finding it so I
know it works for most so just give it
another minute or two and say it's
buffering and then it also some people
are looking for a Dropbox and that's not
the mode I'm using it's just under
assignments and you can just cruise down
and look for the active assignment and
I'll put the ones for summarizing this
lecture and then for the questions for
next week up a little later today so
those aren't up there yet but I should
have them up by this evening and then
office hours if anybody wants to take me
up on that I am always happy to show up
before class to meet over lunch if you'd
like often with our speaker but let me
know so I'm sure to show up if you need
an office hour to contact me any other
time just send me an email there and be
happy to to get in touch with you so
your homework every week is summarizing
the lecture I am saying by Wednesday
this is generating a lot of stress I'm
noticing I would prefer you to summarize
it by Wednesday because it'll be fresh
in your minds but if you're turning it
in later than that I am not working you
down for that this is a past no past
course and if you've got a thoughtful
summary you are getting full marks for
that I also would like you to do some
reading for the next lecture what I
suggest or something on your own just so
you're thinking about with the next
lecture is and email me at least one
burning question I've been saying by
Sunday but then by the time they all
trickle in that comes to Monday and that
seems maybe a little late for our
lectures so if you could actually aim if
we could aim to have most of them in by
Friday at least some preliminary
questions that would be helpful I could
be sending the first wave to our
lecturers early on that would be good
and then for next week excuse me I have
to tuck exactly yes I wanted to make
sure this this was showing up for SCPD
students
for next week I'm going to put up a
paper that actually discusses my own
project that has come out recently I
have the author's permission to do it on
soft geo-engineering but it will allow
you to see why I think ice is so darned
critical in climate it discusses a
number of interesting options but this
is one of them and then these these
optional books you really you really are
free to carry them around and build your
muscles or even read them on thin ice
and ice in the ocean
tymberlee wailing I think we have a
scrappy book or two that is floating
around the class if anybody wants that
we've got the what I wish I knew when I
was 20 floating around the class if
anybody's dying to see that it's a good
one and I will unlock the SGS eye 2007
class the Wednesday readings on climate
that you can read on the website as well
it's about time to ask you folks to
suggest readings meetings lectures I
think I will make that part of next
week's homework
it's just please suggest something so
that we're broadening the knowledge base
of the class and the week after that be
warned I will be asking has anybody
thought of a research term project again
pass no pass no pressure but that you
would like to dive in a little bit and
do a two minute presentation on during
some time during the last few weeks of
class I think it would add a lot
information opportunities the jiseop
meeting last week was fantastic as it
always is and they're going to put
videos up of all of it I think at the
end of the month and you you who knew
that students could go did you get to go
to a lot No okay did anybody actually
have time to go to it okay great okay
okay and what did you think I get amazed
by that the tutorials seem to be getting
better and better and they yeah it's I
was I was blown away as always it was
good coming up soon this MIT Club of
Northern California you don't have to be
MIT affiliated to go
is coming up the smart-grid meeting
those are fun if you've got a car and
can get there and the cleantech open
still an open invitation of if anybody
wants the discount from rex northern to
attend you could get that that's that's
two days of real inspiration and the AG
you the American Geophysical Union I'm
I'm interested in that one happens in
San Francisco in a while so as we've
said entrepreneurs will find
opportunities in climate challenges and
Don is one example that we will see of
how how one does that business needs
environmentalists and environmentalists
need business I believe that from the G
set meeting what solar energy is taking
advantage of are these exergy resources
exergy is basically thinks it is energy
but in its most useful implementation so
it's not just low low energy
differential like a temperature
difference of a degree that's very hard
to harness it is more concentrated
harness Abul type of energy and solar
radiation boy there's one of them right
so that's that's what power is the solar
industry and we've got a lot of
insulation on the planet and so this is
this is really what's being harnessed if
you can harness sunlight you're doing a
very good thing for green energy right
although it comes down to storage is a
lot of it which we'll get to later in
the quarter as well you'll find a couple
battery oriented talks so dawn fold an
hour manufacturing director at Alta
devices survived Solyndra but I know
some of you have questions about and
started out as a semiconductor person so
very very neat background I think
relevant to where a lot of you may be
coming from or going to yourselves and
let's give a warm welcome thanks for
being here
we go so I hope we're on right you guys
can all hear me alright ok good so I
just wanted to tell you I spent about 16
to 17 years in the semiconductor
industry and then I went on from there
to the renewable energy industry from
hydrogen fuel cells and then into solar
so I spent the last probably eight years
in renewables I've done design
engineering from early in my career all
the way to manufacturing marketing this
sort of thing so had a broad background
and one of the fortunate things about
the the semiconductor industry is that
it was so widespread across the globe
that I got to go travel around the world
and see how people are using energy I've
been passionate about energy since I was
a little kid and so I always wanted to
get into solar but I never thought it
was the right time yet for solar until
about eight years ago and so I've worked
in large companies and in startups as
well and so I just wanted to give you a
bit of a background so you understand
where I'm coming from and the reason
we're talking about PV is because it's
got about an 80% cumulative annual
growth rate and so it's hard to find an
industry like this so people say well
you know the caveat to this is you're
starting at near zero so if you're
starting at zero your growth rates going
to be enormous and so but it's
sustainable and it's a continued growth
rate and it continues to ramp up over
time and I'll show you some numbers of
where we think it's going and it's
because you know fossil fuels are
getting more expensive and people are
demanding more clean energy the other
part is that the PVD PV for photovoltaic
it's been steadily declining in price
because as they continue to put more and
more capacity online you can see that
the costs come down
the economies of scale kick in and so
what we're seeing is this top-line is
what's happening with what we call
crystal silicon and I'll talk to you
about different types of solar year in a
minute but crystal silicon is on a
pretty steady growth or pretty state
price drop path and then we see the
second line air is thin film and this is
a First Solar one of the largest players
in thin film and so you pretty much have
thin film and crystal silicon the two
types of solar and so if you see that
we're on a eighty percent cumulative
cumulative annual growth rate and you
see this price reduction you can see why
people are jumping into it and there's a
lot of other reasons incentives and
other things that are driving people
there but it's a pretty good cost
reduction curve that we see continuing
this is the different types of solar so
if you look up here in the upper left
hand corner there's different types of
solar cells multi-junction cells where
they stack multiple solar cells in one
there's these crystal silicon cells
where it's a single crystalline cell one
Junction and you can see there's
different thin film technologies there
in the green the top is cigs which is
copper indium gallium diselenide cadmium
telluride which is what First Solar is
known for and then the more facility and
some other other types of the red here
is the emerging PV and you see it's way
down here on the bottom curve and those
are things like dye sensitized in in
essence it's kind of artificial
photosynthesis methodologies so there's
some new techniques coming out in that I
don't know a lot about that area because
it's it's up-and-coming and it's not
something that I pursued it's a very
low-end type of a solar so but I know
that there's the the catalyst that
they're looking at our new things in
titanium titanium oxide cobalt oxide and
getting away from manganese as a
catalyst but it's a cheap form of solar
and so it doesn't produce a lot but it's
cheap so in the end what we really care
about is everybody would say well why
don't we go with the
efficiency up there and the reason is
this cost so in the end when you're
you're putting solar somewhere whether
you're a power company putting it out in
the desert or a homeowner putting it on
your rooftop what you care in the end is
cost per watt that's what you that's
what you're after and so in the end it
doesn't matter how efficient the thing
is if it cost you a fortune so you know
you want this the best efficiency for
space applications satellites so they go
with gallium arsenide because it's got
the highest but they're willing to pay a
premium for it because it's low weight
and high efficiency but you know if
you're gonna build a solar farm out in
the desert all you care about is how
much it cost you in the end how much
you're gonna produce for how much it
gonna cost you so there's these are I
lifted this from the NREL website but it
shows all the different types and it
shows the efficiencies are continuing to
grow up over time so if you see that the
growth in terms of solar is going up the
costs are coming down the efficiency is
going up all things are going in the
right direction
they haven't leveled off yet they're
still continually climbing so it tells
tells us that solar is on its way and in
a good path so I wanted to show you in
terms of demand PV demand this is kind
of the market you see a large chunk of
this the green area the green shaded
area is mostly Europe and this over here
is a Asia and the US but as you see in
2013 it's shrinking in Europe because
not because the size of Europe's getting
smaller it's because Asia is kicking
into gear so you have to remember that
when it comes to PV you can put it
anywhere you can put it on a rooftop you
can put it on your calculator right you
can put it just about anywhere it's not
like a nuke plant where you got to build
it out in some secluded area and you
know it costs you a fortune you can put
PV anywhere so the thing about having PV
anywhere is that a lot of these places
they don't have a grid there's no grid
so in the US you drop in a power plant
somewhere you connect to the grid and
you're on your way selling power but for
a lot of these people they can't even
get to a grid you know there's places in
Africa and India and China where they
have no grid yet so if you're one of
these people and you want electricity
you know you're one of your choices
winter or or solar so it's really
important that when what we see now is
that Europe is a fantastic power grid
euro s has a fantastic power grid and so
people were really adopting there
they're still going after that but now
we're really seeing Asia kick into gear
and we're seeing other countries kick
into gear in Africa and South America
where a PV gives you you know a lot of
luxuries that most people take for
granted so the the tricky thing is is
that manufacturing probably closer to 40
percent was done in the u.s. about five
to six years ago now it's a closer to
four percent in the US and the reason is
is that the majority that has gone to
China and they're making crystal silicon
solar it's the predominant thing that's
coming out of China right now in terms
of PV so as China really kicks into gear
it brought those prices down because you
had so much more production coming on
board this is your typical solar panel
that everybody sees you know you think
about solar this is what you see a blue
panel up on somebody's rooftop but what
you have to remember is that there
there's a lot of different applications
for solar and a lot of different places
that they're putting solar so you can
put it on a rooftop like you're like you
know I was telling you about you can
have solar power plants or what we call
solar farms out in the mountain remote
areas take a big chunk to land and start
dropping in a bunch of solar plants a
solar solar panels on on a big array and
so that's what you see up here in the
corner so they put them in the desert
they put them in nice areas they put
them in a lot of different places I've
seen them in Europe along the freeways
they've put them along the Autobahn and
things because they're using its they're
using good land instead of turning
farmland into solar farms they're using
usable land like freeways and things
like this you see a lot of commercial
and public stuff these are harder to
spot because you know usually as a
parapet around the outside of a building
you don't get to see the actual solar on
the roof a lot of companies are trying
to showcase it to say that they're going
green you know Walmart and Target
these guys are trying to do stuff Costco
their alternative applications
everything like I said from solar tents
for soldiers to solar covers for cell
phones you can go on the web now and buy
a solar battery charger for your cell
phone there are all different types of
things the calculator you know they've
had solar calculators since the 70s so
there's a lot of different applications
for the the trick is is what kind of
efficiencies do you need and what kind
of cost per watt you really need and
that's what drives you kind of in
different applications and different
types of solar to put in those
applications so there's major solar
technology I talked about the crystal
silicon either mono crystalline or multi
and the thin film there's amorphous
silicon cigs and cad-tel and so these
are the typical thin film and the reason
we're talking about thin film is instead
of consuming a wafer the crystal silicon
you take a wafer of silicon and you
consume it as part of your solar cell
the thin films they're able to go to a
thinner film and they can put it on
glass or stainless steel or aluminum as
a back sheet and so they're doing it
some of it on plastic so they're getting
creative but it's what you would
consider a thin film because here the
wafers are you know in the hundreds of
microns over there you know talking a
couple of microns of of actual solar
cell on a thicker back sheet so crystal
silicon is about ninety percent of the
market that's why when the Chinese
kicked into gear on the crystal silicon
really dropped the prices significantly
for solar around or across the board the
thin film guys had to come down as well
so if you think about that cost curve
people asked me about Solyndra so one of
the things that killed a lot of solar
startups in the in the Bay Area here a
lot of solar starts around the world's
because that growth at that cost
reduction curve was so steep that people
just couldn't keep up with it they said
I'll I can make a profit at this price
point and then the price point changed
and they had to change their business
model and so they were chasing this this
rapidly decreasing price curve and so a
lot of them couldn't keep up it's one of
the issues with Sol
Solyndra but a lot of other issues I'll
tell you at the end
typically when we talk about solar we're
talking about semiconductors so same
semiconductors you would use in the
others you see silicon here at 14
germanium but a lot of people are using
something gallium here and arsenide and
so that you take gallium and arsenic you
still end up in the semiconductor range
the CAD tell people are using cadmium
and telluride and the cigs people are
using copper indium gallium and selenium
and so they're combining these together
in the right ratios to get a good
semiconductor to get what you need from
the solar properties so I was showing
this earlier this is basically your
silicon solar construction so you start
with poly silicon you make an ingot you
slice the ingot into wafers you take
those wafers and you put some metal on
them and and and treat them you end up
with a solar cell you take a bunch of
these solar cells you put them together
into a solar panel you can see this
solar panel if you look closely you see
all these different dots the white is
the corners of these wafers the black is
where the solar cell is so if you look
up in the corner there you can see those
are all cells so you put a bunch of
cells together into a module and you put
on your rooftop and in terms of cost
this is where a lot of the cost is
driven from so the solar cell production
is not very much of the cost structure
the majority of it is really putting it
on your roof so if I give you a solar
panel where is the most of the cost goes
it's the installation
it's the inverter system it's the
racking on your rooftop it's a you know
this is the where the cost goes so 50
percent of it is putting here on the
roof and that number is actually going
up because this piece of the value chain
is going down but the roof racking and
everything hasn't gone down at the same
rate so roof racking
so that's for your typical solar and it
doesn't matter whether you're racking it
on a roof or you're racking it out on a
solar farm in the desert so in the end
like I told you it's about solar energy
costs how much does it cost you so cost
per watt so how much can you get out of
this thing for
much you put into it so the solar cell
operation just for those of you who are
not used to it basically a light comes
in a photon strikes an atom separates
out all electron hole pair the electron
goes down the metal path out the top the
hole meets down here and it comes down
through your load and comes back it's a
pretty simple process it's very simple
when you start to think about it
there's a lot of innovative things that
people are doing to try and get more out
of it and there's a lot of different
papers out there on how to get more out
of this so one of the problems you have
is that these are the holes can meet up
with another electron and basically give
out a piece of light you know a little
bit of photon and so you end up with
losing that ability to generate
electricity so your goal is to try and
make sure that you don't end up with the
recombination and I'll talk about losses
here in a second this is your typical
structure you have your front your back
the back is a is a good reflector so
anything that any photons that make it
all the way through hit the reflector
and come back you have a chance to catch
them on the rebound
the texturize the surface so it's an
anti-reflective coating when you when
you have the light coming in if it's
reflective in any way that light bounces
off you've lost that ability to generate
from that so you end up with a solid
metal typically on the back on the top
you want these lines thin lines so you
allow more light to come in so you're
not blocking the light you don't want
any shading or shadowing so typically
you know you've got this big thick
silicon wafer 200 microns to me is thick
but and then on the top you have a very
thin layer that your of silicon that
you've doped in order to make this work
so I was talking about losses there's a
lot of different ways you can lose you
can have reflective losses where the
light hits the the top metal and bounces
off it can hit the actual solar area and
bounce off because of you don't have a
good answer reflective coating you can
end up with recombination losses I was
talking about where an electron hole
pair you've created where the photon
ends up meeting up with some other
electron or hole in bam you've got it
Photon and you have no electricity
generating so there's a lot of light
back light absorption so when the light
hits it absorbed instead of reflecting
so there's a lot of things that you want
to make sure that when you talk about a
solar cell how do you how do you get the
most efficiency out of it so the
material is very important that's why I
was showing you the different types of
materials gallium arsenide being one of
the better ones these dye sensitized
ones being the lower ones and so what I
wanted you to understand is that the
material can make a lot of difference
but there's a lot of little techniques
that you can do in here a better
reflector a better anti-reflective
coating a lot of different things that
help improve the solar cell efficiency
so the solar production by region I was
explaining China it's it was really hot
in Germany and the reason it was big in
Germany is because a lot of the research
was being done in Germany and so the
Germans were really smart about this
they got clever they they put in a
feed-in tariff which made people
attracted to solar and so solar kicked
off really high in Germany and everybody
was putting solar on their rooftops
because it paid the you actually turned
a profit so people were borrowing money
in order to put solar on the roof
because they knew that over time they
could make money on it and the banks
were lending because they knew that they
got a sure return on it so Germany was
one of the big leaders in this with
their feet in tariffs a lot of others in
Europe started to do the same Spain
Italy Portugal have all kicked in with
solar feed-in tariffs and it's really
spurred a lot of growth in those areas
as well but the the production started
to go away from Germany they've got high
manufacturing costs of course their
labour costs are high the land is high
everything becomes expensive and so it
started migrating away from Germany and
off towards China and the same thing has
happened in the US so when you talk
about funding for solar there's a lot of
different people trying to figure out
ways to make the solar more efficient
more cost advantageous so there's been a
lot of venture funding that has gone
into solar so you see solar the solar
itself the efficiency in terms of like
smart grid and
sort of thing has been funded a lot
biofuels and storage are being funded
took these specifically because they
relate to the solar industry people are
still you know there's venture funds
going after wind and and other things
but biomass and things like this but
really I thought these were more germane
to the topic here hand the US Treasury
program I'm not going to spend a lot of
time on but they're spending a lot of
money on solar as you can see here the
number of projects since its inception
in 2009 some of these programs
died on the vine and it's because they
were competing with you know China they
couldn't they couldn't sustain that that
drop in price and so they went in with
great intentions and a great business
plan but as the market changed they
weren't able to change rapidly enough so
a lot of them died but this but a lot of
that innovation that was being done at
these small startups has been taken by
others and is using to foster the entire
industry
so I know in a way it's helped so I
wanted to talk about innovation so about
a third of all the R&D global funds are
spent in the u.s. that most of the
venture funds are really spending it
here the the u.s. leads of course in R&D
and we've got 200 in 2011 about 400 PV
patents been granted and about seventy
six percent of the PV venture investment
has been in North America so I wanted to
tell you this because PV is sort of in
its infancy it's been around since the
you know 1800s they've known about
photovoltaics but it's really in its
infancy and it's taking off now it's
really growing and so this innovation is
really what's kicking in you see that
that efficiency curves are growing and
growing so it's because there's a lot of
money being poured into it to get better
efficiency programs so when you're
talking about a lot of companies that
start off they have to cross something
called the valley of death the reason we
talk about this is you get a lot of
venture funding and you can go on the
cheap when you're doing R&D you can do
something
and test tubes and this kind of stuff
you can do a lot of stuff when it comes
to R&D but at some point you got to get
off of R&D and you got to get into
putting a production line together
because at some point you have to make a
product to sell so a lot of these guys
that come in and get some government
investment or industry investment they
work their way over to get some angel
investors that work the way up to
venture capital they're driving their
product forward everything is a go and
they have to cross that valley of death
and so a lot of people they don't
understand that when you want to build a
factory it's a two-year thing so for two
years you're you're you know you're
spending money on a building spending
money on capital equipment spending
money and you haven't gotten anything
back yet and so that spend we typically
say it's a 3/3 a third of its the
capital equipment a third of its the
money for the building and land and and
the infrastructure in the building and
the other third is the burn because for
you know two years it's going to take
you to get from the time you break
ground until you're ready to start you
know turning out revenue it's about two
years to do this that's a lot of burn
and so big factories burn a tower an
enormous rate so you get some great
economies of scale with a big factory
but of course it burns like crazy so a
lot of these companies they try and get
through this valley of death and they
fail because it's it's really the
toughest part so many great startups out
there have died because they couldn't
get through the valley of death so the
same thing goes for all these solar
startups they went in and with great
intentions they get did great stuff
they're able to do it on the cheap do a
lot of research analysis they get to
that point where they said okay let's go
and build a factory and holy mackerel
they all start dying and it's because
the the the crossing that valley death
is so difficult so I want you understand
that because it's not just solar it's
any industry doesn't matter what you're
doing if you're if you have to build a
factory you're going to be hemorrhaging
cash for a while so raising that money
is so difficult a lot of companies try
it with an IPO or they try it with you
know going out and
getting more VC funding but the VC guys
don't want to jump into something that
big so you see a lot of companies that
you know have trouble they got a great
product great concept they can't get
across that valley of death so there's a
lot of beer PV startups so nanosolar is
still alive Mia Silla is still alive day
stars dead a lot of these companies are
dead or dying and it's because they
couldn't get through that valley of
death they couldn't get the
manufacturing off the ground and so but
you see there's so many of them jumping
in and a lot of them you see we're
jumping into thin film the cigs in the
end more facility on the the guys that
jumped into the silicon had an unique
idea about how they could cut costs of
the wafer een make a thinner wafer this
kind of stuff and so unfortunately a lot
of them like I said I don't know maybe
half of these companies are not alive or
they're walking wounded ready to die
soon so um it has to do with
manufacturing in the u.s. it's not sure
where Alta will do their manufacturing
you know it has to do with you know it's
cheap to go to Asia and build a
manufacturing plant in Asia because the
labor is cheaper the land is cheaper
there's a lot of good subsidies there
but in the end it's a big leap to go
overseas to something and so there's a
lot of question about should we do it in
the US and run the risks of higher costs
higher operating expenses versus going
somewhere else where maybe it's a
cheaper operating expenses and so
there's a lot of trade-offs there when
it comes to manufacturing so like I said
the manufacturing is the key to any of
these companies getting off the ground
it's the they can do a lot in the lab
it's when you you really the it
separates the men from the boys when you
have to go to manufacturing so what was
your question the same company or or
similar to Alta Energy it's a different
company
I work for all two devices so let's see
the challenges I was explaining the time
it takes to get you off the ground to
get through the design phase selecting
the site getting through all the
negotiations the state negotiations for
incentives that the contractor is all
this sort of stuff getting the
construction done installing all the
machines starting them up getting them
qualified before you can start to ship
product and this time period takes so
long that you really have to be prepared
to go in and you know spend this money
at an enormous rate with no return for a
while and so if you've got revenue and
you're showing a good profit and
everything is a go you can get money to
build the next factory or the next
factory but if you haven't built
anything haven't gotten through the
manufacturing phase a lot of people are
reluctant to give you money so there's a
lot of reasons why you know in the u.s.
this manufacturing becomes a real
challenge not so far
it's a good question they yeah in
semiconductors what we have is something
called a fabless we call the factories
fabs and they have a fabulous model so
you could design a great chip and you go
to somebody like a tsmc or
GlobalFoundries and you say will you
build this for me and they'll take it on
and they'll be they'll do the
manufacturing for you and you pay them a
premium and so if you do well enough
make enough money you can do your own
manufacture or you could stick with the
fabulous guys but it helps you get off
the ground before you have to go and do
something like that
so the fabs are able to do this a little
bit differently in semiconductor because
of the way you build the chip is very
similar in solar the volumes are higher
and you know in semi you're talking
about machines that maybe do 20 units an
hour in solar you're looking at machines
that do 2,000 to 3,000 units an hour so
huge jump as well as the like I said
there's a lot of different
a lot of different ways they're going so
you couldn't just go to a fab and say
hey can you build this for me because
they may not have the right machines
they may not have the right processes
this sort of thing so it makes it more
difficult so that's why a lot of people
are going there they're doing their own
manufacturing and it's very difficult so
I wanted to talk about the supply chain
a bit because about two billion dollars
a positive contribution so far in trade
with China we've got a real healthy PV
supply chain meaning the machines the
chemicals this sort of stuff about a
hundred thousand US jobs in the solar
industry in 2011 and this is everything
from the guys that put the stuff on the
roof to people that maybe work at I
don't know DuPont or Dow making
chemicals for the thing or you know
people that the gas companies making
specialty gases and things there's a lot
of different jobs that you wouldn't
think of but they're in the supply chain
and about 5,000 US companies in the
solar value chain so I was explaining
there's equipment people they
manufacture the equipment there's
materials people like Dow DuPont
Matheson there's a lot of people that do
the silicon re C is the u.s. plan Vaca
is a u.s. plant these guys are making
the actual wafers and then there's out
here on the sale production in the
module production mostly startups and so
these jobs here are very important to
the solar the solar industry itself and
like I said it's it's a huge amount of
jobs that are here in the US even if
some of the production is done overseas
there's still a lot of jobs here in the
supply chain so I wanted to talk about
PV jobs and then the majority of these
jobs here are in installation
you know the manufacturing is very small
and it's shrinking
the sales in marketing and sales and
distribution piece is a big so you
understand why this is the way it is
it's because there's not a lot of
manufacturing if there were more
manufacturing jobs and you know the pie
would change but the manufacturing has
been going overseas so the important
thing about manufacturing we you know
it's an election year everybody
jobs jobs jobs is that manufacturing
jobs really generate downstream jobs
more than a lot of the others so you
know you get two utility jobs education
jobs they're really important but they
don't generate the downstream jobs like
a manufacturing job does because if you
do manufacturing you have to have all
the supply chain and so they talked
about me they talked about jobs right
now it's a it's a big topic in the
election but what they're missing is
where do the jobs really we need to be
working all areas but the manufacturing
jobs have disappeared so um it's one of
the problems in this in the u.s. so when
I talk about manufacturing manufacturing
helps supply all these things equipment
R&D supply chain all these things are
really important it helps drive these so
the future global PV mix I was talking
to you earlier about there's residential
capacity has been growing commercial
capacity is growing these are commercial
rooftops the utility scale is growing
these are utility scales owned by the
power companies out in the deserts and
stuff and then off-grid is really an
important piece and this one's growing
significantly the reason it is is like I
said there's you know a huge chunk of
the world population who has no access
to the grid they just don't they have no
way to connect so I know I was in Africa
a couple years ago the guys asked me if
I would take his cell phone to the city
and give it to this guy and he basically
I was going through his village he gave
me a cell phone well then the next next
thing I knew four or five more guys were
giving me their cell phones and saying
can you take you to the city I don't why
they trusted me with their cell phone
but the whole thing was they couldn't
charge it where they were at they needed
they had they had the Wi-Fi network
right I mean the the cell network but
they had no way to charge their
batteries so I had to take it in and
give it to this guy who charges all the
batteries for these guys they actually
had a guy who has a in a different place
had a battery a car battery he lugged
around with him and he would sit down
and he would charge your phone for you
and people paid him money to do this
because they have no grid so a guy with
a solar cell on his backyard can you
know charge up all these people's cell
phones it's amazing what they're they
just want a cell phone charger so
off-grid is really grown
and it's in countries you wouldn't think
of you think about South America there's
huge areas of the populace that down
there that have no access to a grid
China there's you know it's it's it's
amazing when you go there there's tons
of huge cities but there's a bunch of
people out in the rural areas have no
access to grid India same sort of thing
India's really got a big problem
there they're having tons of brownouts
because the power demand is going up
higher and higher every day and they're
not able to keep up with your
conventional grid connection so the u.s.
energy makes this is a real important
one I want you guys to see from the
lawrence livermore in that labs you can
see that solar is just a real small
piece of the pie right now
and when you look at it this is
electricity generation up here so all
these feed into electricity generation
the rest of it is used for you know
other purposes like transportation
industrial commercial residential these
types of things like residential you
still use petroleum for heating in a lot
of places in the Northeast but this is
what the US has done this is the US and
you can get this state-by-state and
understand where it's coming from state
by state if you go to the website the
real interesting thing is natural gas is
growing rapidly and it's shrinking coal
and petroleum pretty pretty fast and so
there's a lot of people about killing
coal jobs in the US the real interesting
thing is that they've been building a
lot of natural gas plants there was an
article in the paper about Georgia
building all these natural gas power
plants and turning off their coal plants
because it's just you know it's dirty it
there's a lot of problems with
regulation around the areas with cold
due to you know the dust for kids with
asthma and other things health issues
and just the the regulations around it
so they're they're putting in natural
gas and of course the fracking thing in
the US has turned on a lot of cheap
natural gas it's it's been dropping
amazingly so if you look at this energy
mix this is for 2010 they've got more
updated ones I wasn't able to grab
quickly enough but you can see it you
can see it break down by state so you
know Washington State lots of hydro
power West Virginia lots of coal so
you'll see the different mixes and
but this is the US as a whole and you
can see one of the worst things that
really kills you I don't know if you
guys have caught it yet
is the upper right hand corner it's
called rejected energy that's energy
that was produced and wasted so an
example might be the heat in your car is
wasted right the engine produces a lot
of heat but that he is just wasted you
you know there's no way to capture that
so that's wasted energy a lot of
electricity during transmission is
radiated so you you don't capture that
so there's a lot of electricity a lot of
power that's just wasted in forms so if
you think about this is an enormous
amount of electricity or power this is
all measured and basically BTUs enormous
amount of energy that's just wasted so
that's why you know efficiency is an
important piece of this so I wanted to
talk about net generation capacity the
European Union has been adding pretty
pretty significantly over the years you
see out here they were really doing a
lot with wind they were doing a lot with
gas to get away from nuke and coal and
petroleum but as you see around 2005
when they kicked in with the the feed-in
tariffs Europe took off this is
predominantly Germany's was driving this
but Peavy took off and it's been growing
pretty steadily and it's in the feed-in
tariffs phased out over time they've
been they've been reducing year over a
year and so even with the feed-in
tariffs going down people are still
installing solar the Fukushima disaster
in in Japan with the tsunami a year or
so ago it basically they started turning
off all the nuke plants in Europe and so
by turning those off they had to drive
towards more PV more wind other things
so I wanted to show you Germany is the
biggest chunk of this in terms of the
these countries with the feed-in tariffs
but others are starting to grow it and
as you see is the share of PV
electricity production continues to go
up and the cost of GDP are going up you
see that the big players are out here
Germany
Italy but the rest of them are chasing
as well this is an interesting graph
before solar this is what it looked like
the the average across the day 24 hours
here there's this huge demand in the
middle of the day for of course you know
all the people are going to school or go
into the industry and they're turning on
needing electricity but this is the
perfect time for PV because that's when
it works the best in the middle of the
day and so the summer after solar this
is what it looks like your your average
prices and it has to do with the fact
that you know Solar works perfectly for
the peak demand so there's this big
issue when you have a power plant you
want to run it at capacity because if
you're running it low is basically this
asset is not being fully utilized so
your goal is to try and make sure that
you run it at peak well the problem is
is that the electricity demand
throughout the day changes so you end up
with this these giant factory or giant
power plants that have to match that
peak demand and then during the rest of
the time they're not they're not matched
anymore the the acids sitting there not
usable so solar actually worked really
well because it's best time is during
the day when the demand is there and so
they're using it to level eyes this
thing to take away that peak demand so
now they're not putting in huge huge
power plants that are sitting idle
during the day they've got this solar
that works at the right time in the
winter what do you mean in the winter
this the divan matches pretty pretty
steadily as well so you don't have to
install more there's a lot of
electricity for heat in the in Europe as
well okay yeah so it's not like the u.s.
very little electricity generation for
heat it's more for like for gas and oil
and this sort of thing but in Europe
they still use a lot electricity and so
this is the spot power price you know by
our going across the day and so instead
of a former lunchtime peak the there is
actually an afternoon trough now so this
is the price of power so it's really
helping in places like that so
really interesting thing is Leslie was
talking about insulation it's the
measure of how much electricity you you
know how much solar energy is being
received in that spot so when you look
at the insulation map of the globe
Germany is actually probably much more
closer aligned to the amount of
insulation of Alaska than it is to other
places and yet the world leader in terms
of you know installing solar power and
it's because they recognize that even
though they don't have the best
insulation they have the best model here
for how to demand how to drive solar and
how to utilize it the best so they're
working out really well for them so I
wanted to show you this if you watch the
blue line anything up into the upper
right of this line shows that you reach
kind of like they people talk about grid
parity and it means that the cost of
installing solar and the costs of you
know of solar on the upper right it
actually is paid off now it's cheaper
than you know the other forms of
electricity in those areas and so if you
see this is 2010 and the line steps to
the left and down so you pick up Italy
and Spain and as you come across the
2012 Germany Denmark Australia you start
to kick in and this is because in these
places they don't have cheap electricity
or they tax it either way you can either
and send somebody to do something or
penalize them to do something either way
they'll do something right there they
want to get away from it so Brazil kicks
in as you get to 2013 California Turkey
France and as you march across all these
things start to kick in by 2020
you know you've picked up a lot of these
big countries that are big demand I want
to talk about solar jobs so roughly 33
jobs per megawatt for solar is I talked
about that big value chain and all this
kind of stuff a lot of supply a lot of
different people to install and
everything and jobs for per megawatt for
a new less than 10 so you know the the
difference here is that people talk
about you know why should we go to solar
there's a lot
reasons to go to solar there's a lot of
reasons to go to renewables this is one
of them because it shows that it pays
off eventually a lot of people are
talking about well when does it reach
great parity and I was showing you those
slides there's a lot of places where
they don't need grid parity because
there is no there is no grid you know
there's places where Indonesia is a huge
population and they have most of their
countries islands and so on those
islands they have a diesel generator
that that generates it so there they
have to pay diesel so what you're not
trying to do is match grid parity you're
trying to do diesel parity so you're so
you're taking a different model a
different approach there's places in
India where they don't have a grid and
so they use kerosene like light yet and
so when you're trying to match this
you're not for the person who just wants
light you're trying to match kerosene
parity not in grid parity cuz there is
no grid so when you start thinking about
a lot of the world majority of them out
there don't have access to this grid
when you think about what are you trying
to match it's not grid parity in the
u.s. grid parity is really difficult to
hit we've got the best grid in the world
we've got cheap power it's amazing so
trying to chase the grid parity in the
u.s. is tough they're getting better at
it
but the Solar has so many places it can
play and do well at so this is an
interesting one this was a apparently
before Steve Jobs passed away here in
Palo Alto they Obama came to visit him
and they had kind of a forum discussion
it's in the Steve Jobs book and Obama
apparently asked him you know what would
it take to to start building iPhones in
the US and he said the jobs are not
coming back and the reason is is once
you lose the jobs it's so much harder to
get him to come back so the point is is
don't lose the jobs in the first place I
was telling you before about 40% of all
solar panels made in the u.s. that was
maybe seven or eight years ago now less
than 4% and it's crazy so those jobs
went overseas they're not coming back so
it's hard it's hard to start producing
those jobs back again so the goal is not
to lose them in the first place so I had
some slides I won't spend a lot of time
on you know recommendations on US policy
telling you that you can in sent
somebody by penalizing them or giving
them a reward right so see that the
carrot or the stick and sometimes both
work well and so when you think about
the carrot or the stick if you give them
a feed-in tariff that's the carrot you
give them penalties in terms of
regulations and taxes it drives them the
same either way your your people will
decide based on their wallet I kept
telling you before cost per walk right
that's what people care about so you
know kerosene in India it's like 60
dollars a watt
diesel somewhere in the neighborhood of
$40 a lot so I don't have to do much to
get to great parity there I mean to get
to some kind of parity there you know
when I can make solar modules that
produce electricity you know somewhere
in the neighborhood now of close to $1 a
watt maybe some place is less than a
buck a watt so if you can do a buck a
lot versus $60 a lot there's no reason
why so a lot of these countries are
recognizing this linear starting to
drive policy towards this to try and get
these places you know connected with an
off-grid type of a system so these are
you can utilize a ways to try and drive
more investment in solar and more
consumption of solar so to kind of
calibrate to the growth about 15
gigawatts of new solar capacity but new
nuke capacity is about 3 gigawatts and
this is growing more and more as I
showed with the very first slide which
is the 80 percent cumulative annual
growth rate and so nuke after the
Fukushima disaster and Three Mile Island
and Chernobyl people are starting to get
more and more afraid of it people are
more and more afraid of coal and
petroleum because you're kind of held
hostage by petroleum by any issues in
the Middle East coals is a dirty process
people are starting to realize the total
cost of something is not how much it
takes you to buy the coal but how much
it costs you in terms of environmental
issues in terms of health issues all
these other issues so that's changing
the way people are thinking so some of
you guys asked me questions about
Solyndra know under to tell you
like I said Solyndra model started they
were gonna be profitable and do well at
four dollars a watt and I told you it's
now down to $1 a watt and they chased
that curve down and it was hard for them
all the way down they had a good product
good good concept but they weren't able
to make money at the lower levels they
were starting to do the right things
there was innovation people are doing
the right stuff but they just couldn't
get there fast enough the other thing
that kind of hurt them was that the
government incentive the way it was
written forced them to spend at an
exorbitant rate to chase this this
schedule so they were spending like
crazy - in order to hit the schedule
constantly they basically said you know
here's tranches of money based on
hitting these milestones you know you
got to do all this and you get your next
chunk of money do all this and get your
next chunk of money you need to do it on
a certain scale time scale so really
kind of hurt them on top of that it was
written the original loan was written so
that you know typically in a bankruptcy
or something goes wrong everybody takes
their share of investment away with them
so you know if I owe you 50 percent I
you 20% in the end at the end of a
bankruptcy you get 50 percent of
whatever is left over you get 20 percent
of whatever is left over but the
government said no no no we want a
hundred percent we want to be made one
hundred percent whole before you pay
anybody else well that basically
hamstrung them nobody was willing to
invest is why do I want to invest if I
if I know I'm gonna get zero out of this
or potential of zero because you got to
pay the government and hole first so the
government wouldn't relent they wouldn't
change the terms of the loan and so they
were starting to really get into closer
and closer to the deadline where they
were gonna run out and so at the last
minute they went to the government said
look you're in for a lot of money guys
you either jump on board and change
these terms of the loan so I can get
some more investors and we can make a go
of this or you're gonna end up going
down and you know and we'll sink with
you so the government said okay we'll
change the terms of the loan so they
changed it they changed it too late in
the game
and by the time they change that they
didn't get enough time to get the
venture funding to keep going and so
it's really a sad case because I spent a
lot of time building the factory getting
it going getting it off the ground it
was a really great team of people smart
smart people doing the right things but
sometimes incentives are good if you
look around the rest of the world China
is taken off like a rocket because
they've got tons of incentives they get
free land and free a lot of kids of free
labor in a lot of cases free capital
equipment so people are racing it out to
build solar factories in fact almost
every Province in China has built a
solar factory and it's because they're
thorough the government was throwing
money on it so you come to the US and
they're screaming about how Solyndra got
any money at all and I was really
interested I got in a bit of a
discussion with one of the guys he was
saying oh we shouldn't give this
government shouldn't be in business and
I said what's that's an interesting
thought and he said we lost 500 million
dollars to the in the Solyndra disaster
I said yeah but if you think about this
hypersonic jet it lasted I think the sum
total of two jets was less than 60
seconds of flight and it was 380 million
sitting at the bottom of the Pacific so
I said you know cylinder lasted more
than 60 seconds and those jets didn't so
the two of them at the bottom of the
ocean she said then that doesn't that
that's really the cost of the jets that
doesn't mean the cost of all the R&D
that went into those jets it doesn't
mean it doesn't take into consideration
that we've been trying to chase this
hypersonic jet program since the 60s as
I said it's been billions spent on the
hypersonic jet and we still won't have
one - their flies - at the bottom of the
ocean for 380 million probably billions
spent on the program so when you start
to think about it everybody says well we
got to spend on defense it's really
critical to us I say we got to spend on
energy because it's critical to us you
know when you think about we subsidized
food because you know it's really
critical and we don't want to depend on
another country holding us hostage we
have to have our own defense because we
can't depend on somebody else to police
the world but we say to ourselves well
we'll let ourselves be held hostage by
other countries because you know we want
the oil we want the other other forms of
energy I say you know the that my
personal opinion is is that we subsidize
coal we subsidize all oil we subsidize
gas subsidized other forms of energy and
people are saying we should turn off all
the subsidies for for renewables I think
it's kind of foolhardy because it's an
important piece of the US economy and
it's very strategic in nature that that
we don't tie ourselves to some other
country and being at the mercy of them
and regulating the oil prices so I think
that you know my personal opinion is is
that you know things like Solyndra you
got to invest you got to try and see if
it flies maybe it won't maybe it will
but that's the way to drive things and
innovation and so the I think the u.s.
ought to be doing more of this a lot of
people would say keep the u.s. out of
keep the government out of business I
think they should be investing more
because the competitors I told you we're
at 4% solar in the US when we used to be
40% it all went to China they went there
because they subsidize the heck out of
there out of their industries so you
know we see manufacturing jobs and I
told you manufacturing is an important
piece they you get more downstream jobs
from manufacturing than you do the other
industries then service industries in in
education industries and and these other
industries so I think we really need to
do what we can to keep this the
manufacturing jobs in the US and solar
is one of those opportunities where we
can do more with solar in the US so what
are the questions did you guys have I
tried to look through the questions and
pick slides that answered most of your
questions anything else go ahead
everything about the TV so the problem
you know this the thin film guys are not
high efficiency so they work perfect out
in the desert yacht land land is cheap
so you can build out so I don't care if
I get if let's say I need 100 watts I
can build something this huge or I can
you know build it with on with crystal
silicon there's something like this
right
but residential rooftop I can't use thin
film because I need three houses to
power one I need enough roof area to
power one so thin film doesn't work
great because of the efficiency is low
so it really pushes itself to maybe
commercial rooftops and solar farms so
First Solar the leader in thin film
solar farms that's their big thing but
the crystal silicon guys can play in a
lot of different areas they can do go
out and play in the desert in solar
farms they can play on commercial
rooftops they can prevent play on
residential rooftops so it gives you a
little bit more flexibility so thin film
is struggling in that regard a lot of
people thought thin film would be going
faster and you saw all these solar
starts they were venturing into thin
film because they thought there's a lot
of opportunity there so much energy was
spent on crystal silicon the thin film
guys really were starting to do a lot of
innovative things to get their
efficiencies up and they've really done
a great job of getting their
efficiencies up but the efficiency is
still not in a place where they can play
in a lot of the spaces they're really
relegated to solar farms
and I know it is very encouraging for
people around the world to look at the
employment created by this industry in
China and inspect but I think that is
that what's the case two years ago and
now if you talk about China solar
industry no people in China mostly worry
about whether these enterprises can
survive Mariko's are we created to
manage solar enterprises and we created
the so-called China price and the solar
panels price is so low than the that
this prices enterprises can hardly
survive so in terms of government
subsidy in the US I don't know whether
you may want to avoid such traps to
build too much factories right and the
second one is about the the economics
visibility of the solar panel and as you
just mentioned currently about 50
percent of the cost of end-user cost of
the solar panels incurred in the final
implementation stage and but I think
this is also the place where a lot of
jobs are created and and you also
mentioned that the current lease on a PV
solar PV is very labor intensive and we
all know that the labor is expensive but
people also say that today this solar PV
are not feasible because they are too
expensive for many people and a way to
cut cost is to cut labor intensity so
this seems to be some dilemma here you
want more job creation you want more
labor intensive intensive things then
you have to bear a higher cost that it
prevents its adoption thank you so he
was talking about the cost of the cost
of solar in China it's dropped so
significantly and they built so many
factories that they're basically trying
to cut each other's throats so they're
out there trying to undercut each other
and they're selling a lot of it below
cost
what you see is there's maybe 300
companies that are in solar today around
China those are going to contract down
to you know a handful of larger
companies that can survive this thing
and it's kind of one of the sad things
that they drove too fast and they you
know everybody's putting in solar
factories in without really all knowing
what they're doing and so it was really
a shame because you know they've got
this this issue where a lot of these
companies aren't going to survive the
next couple of years so he was talking
about expanding too quickly and and I
would give you that that any industry
that takes off too rapidly and exceeds
the the supply demand curve will end up
paying the price for it and so
subsidizing it smartly is the right way
to go so just throwing money at
something doesn't help it's like a
desert right too much rain it just runs
off too little rain it's the desert it's
the right amount of rain and things grow
right so the part of this is is that
they went a little too fast in China I
would agree and it caused the price the
market prices to drop crazy I mean I
can't believe how fast they've been
dropping they're probably gonna level
off here a little bit but it's a lot of
these companies that jumped into solar
in China are not gonna survive the next
couple of years and a lot of the larger
companies are going in and buying up
these factors buying the equipment out
of them and leaving shells going so it's
a shame and the you were talking about
the cost of solar you're right a lot of
it is in like I showed you 50% of is in
the insulation piece of it so they're
getting smarter they're - they're
getting more clever one of the big costs
there is permitting so you know we have
a something called the National Electric
Code - NEC and the National Electric
Code
you know governs how you install
different things electrical gear but
they weren't really good about keeping
up with solar and how quickly it turned
on and so this you know like Sunnyvale
has their rules and Mountain View has
their rules and Palo Alto has their
rules and if you're a solar installer
and you're trying to cover these areas
you run off to this guy and he says no
no you had to use this wiring and you
got to put this you know safety device
in and the other places now I want a
different safety
and I want it run different so it's a
huge cost for permitting because we
weren't on the same page when it comes
to this so that's one of the things the
labor is expensive but people were there
weren't a lot of people who knew how to
install them so the guys who were
installing to take a premium and so now
they're changing this they're more and
more people are jumping into you know
solar installations because you see the
money in it so like anything people will
chase the money and it'll cause the
prices to come down on installation as
well the inverter is a big piece of the
cost and they're getting smarter about
inverters as well and the lifetimes of
inverters somebody sent in a question
last night what's the lifetime of solar
so typically most solar manufacturers
assume that they have to have a lifetime
of more than 20 years
so the panel's got to be viable for 20
years it's got to produce there will be
some degradation of efficiency over time
but they recognize that and that they've
but the panel actually has to survive 20
years so they've got panels now that
with an accelerated lifetime testing
that they're showing you know 30 years
of life it's different companies so um I
was trying to think of some of the other
questions you guys were asking about
last night you mentioned this book
something about what would I do
yeah hi I was laughing about that when I
was awake at 2:30 in the morning
thinking about this book and how to
answer this question and so I was
thinking that judgment that's the best
thing I think um you know when when I
was younger I didn't have good judgment
so it was really interesting they talked
about um I remember when four years ago
when Obama was running for office they
they said I was too young and McCain was
the seasoned veteran he knew what he was
doing all this and so he turned it on
this the the argument around and he said
it's about judgment it's not about you
know how many years you've been on the
planet or how many how much years of
experience you have is really about good
judgment
there are people who make great judgment
you know early in their career and
others they have to learn the lesson
many times before they finally get the
judgment so I'd say that you know what I
wish I knew when I was 20 was just
better judgment you know not to speed on
the freeway you know not to go drinking
too much at night you know this kind of
stuff these little simple things you you
think are kind of silly but that's
judgment in my career you know when to
walk away from a job in one to stick it
out when to you know when to let my
emotions show and when not to let your
emotions show these are things where is
just judgment and I think some people
catch it real quickly there's people who
have great judgment early on and there's
others who struggle their whole life
with figuring out what good judgment is
you know and so I think if I had this to
say it one thing that when to know what
to do right and you know when to do it
it's about judgment I was thinking about
you know the fly that buzzes against the
window he never gets through the window
right and at some point you have to say
you don't
am i how long before I give up I'm not
gonna get through this window you know a
lot of flies are dead on the windowsill
in my garage I was thinking about this
and so but there's other times where you
need to think about good judgment then
you know when to turn around and give up
there are other times when I persevered
in things in my career and in my my
marriage in my in life all types of
things I persevered and it paid off in
the end so sometimes you gotta know when
to give up and sometimes you gotta know
when to keep going and that's just
judgment it just comes with figuring it
out and so I don't know I don't know if
the book talks about that but that's
what I would say is the stuff that I
wish I knew then that and what - stuff
to invest in probably there's another
one so what other questions you guys
have
can you maybe talk about the lifecycle
of the solar cell and you have people
started of thinking of ways to recycle
these like at the end of the 20-year
lifetime yeah it's a big it's a big
thing that people are discussing now the
cad-tel people cadmium is obviously a
dangerous material can breathe it can
ingest it so people are worried about
gallium arsenide people are concerned
about this and so there's a lot of
studies being done a lot of work being
done on you know how to recycle these
when it's time and some of the stuff
that is failed early they're looking at
how to catch up the selenium becomes an
issue when you know when selenium hits a
moisture can produce hydrogen selenide
it's a poisonous gas and so a lot of
this that goes into these different
types of solar panels and so there's a
big market kicking into gear on how to
deal with it down the road because
they're just starting to see some of the
really old stuff and some of the early
failures of things how to recycle it so
I told you one of the big costs in the
solar is a silver paste it they put this
silver paste down they screen print it
and that silver paste how do you collect
that silver back because it's valuable
so people are looking at this sort of
thing so there's a market growing on it
I don't know much more about it then I
read the trade journals and this kind of
stuff and I see people talking about
there's articles on it more and more
every day so so thank you for your time
you